you
okay I've got the live on YouTube in top
right corner so I presume we are on now
that'd be confirmed please um I can't
confirm at the moment I've got setting
up being redirected to YouTube so I just
need to wait until I can see it on my
screen I don't know if Chris has got it
on history
we do have about 20 to 30 second delay
as well so that mind at the end of the
meeting yeah all right thank you
okay we've had the confirmation good
morning and welcome to team rich
District Council's planning committee
I'm councillor Mike Haynes chairman of
the committee all participants here
today and taking part remotely and we
are live streaming this meeting on
YouTube please could members confirm
they are present when their name is
called Chris please counselor Linda
Goodman bradbury present councillor
Bradford absolutely
councillor Clarence present councillor
Cox present councillor Hayes present
councillor j-hook councillor Jeffrey
counselor Kira present counselor Jenks
downstairs well present
councillor McGregor isn't counselor at
all
councillor Nuttall present councillor
Nutley councillor pouch present
councillor Parker present council epatha
at present councillor Phipps and
councillor rickly present okay
councillor Haines president yep thank
you
right please good members make sure all
microphones are muted when you're not
speaking to avoid any background noise
levels please keep your points short and
you're not interrupt when someone is
speaking if you wish to comment please
raise your electronic blue hands and
wait to be called any member who does
not care the entire debate relating to
an application is not permitted to vote
on that application during today's
meeting there will be public
participation to those who have
pre-registered to speak when it comes to
the votes the Democratic Services
Officer Chris will read out members
names but members please say if they are
voting for against or abstaining go
introduce the officers who are present
today we have Rose easement who's the
business manager and a holloway who's
the senior planning officer Chris Morgan
trainee democratic services officer and
Trish calls democratic services officer
but if we can move on to the agenda now
then please
item 1 is the minutes to confirm the
minutes of the last meeting which are
attached pages 5 to wait for somebody
there's only one who wishes to raise any
points on those first of all that is
right so as council of Bullivant has
moved the minutes and
they appear second it is second that
second I saw Richard counselor Keeling
secondly that right I don't think we
need as before we don't need to have a
roll call on this if nobody's raising
any concerns with members like to raise
their hands to indicate that they're in
favor of the minutes brings okay so
that's yeah that's fine thank you that's
so many against right thank you seven
minutes are approved item two on the
agenda apologies for absence please
Chris no apologies but counselor Phipps
is not yeah apologies from councillor
Phipps okay thank you
item three is the local government
Access to Information Act that isn't
relevant to any of the applications or
other items thus far so that we'll go
back to that if it should the rise has
been necessary but my motion won't item
for declarations of interest members any
members call a declaration of interest
if you could raise your blue hands
please so some counselor pack Thank You
chairman yes I think it's sensible that
I be considered predetermined on the
ills internal libitum Business Park
application
item number six e on the agenda yeah and
so I shan't participate in the
decision-making on that item but I
understand I'll be able to speak in my
role as ward member yeah that's correct
Thank You councillor Jackie hook thank
you interested in the application
business part relatively
I don't intend to speak Thank You
counsel Wrigley I must also declare that
same interest concerning counselor do
you Hearst and KITT right nobody else is
indicated so I think a Luger is
indicating sorry chair I'm not a
personal friend of counselor do vest
I have been out looked at this site
though um I don't think that should stop
me voting or speaking on the on the
matter
I believe well the decision is yours on
that but that sounds to me that that's
okay
counselor you still got your blue hand
raised I hadn't seen one from counts and
greater just now okay anyone else wish
to declare an interest
no thank you well if anything arises
during the course of the meeting or you
always and cause able to to interject at
that point right that was item for item
five is public participation there are a
number of speakers for the applications
it's only the second application that
there is nobody down to speak what will
happen is that the speakers will be
brought in from the deals in the lobby
into the meeting before we actually
start so there might be a slight delay
whilst they're actually brought into the
meeting but once I know they're present
and then we'll start okay and members of
the public you've been advised if you're
watching on YouTube that you have three
minutes or five minutes or ten if it's
the major application which is the last
one and they'll explain that when we get
to it quiet in which case that takes us
on to item 6 which is the applications
for consideration the first one is the
people pen so I need to just pause
whilst John Phillips
is brought in from the lobby to the
meeting if you could confirm that one
that's done please somebody Germany
looks John's just joining us now mr.
Phillips's right okay I see John's down
there so yes yeah okay thank you
right in which case then rose is there
anything up further update on this
application thank you Kay I'm I would
like to introduce the application and to
make sure members are familiar with the
site before the debate takes place as we
can't have the presentation running in
the background as we would if we were in
the chamber there are no further updates
on this one and can you confirm you can
see my screen okay yeah and so just to
remind everybody that we'll do this
process for every application and one of
the officers will introduce the scheme
take you through the plans and the
images that we've got of the site and
then we'll take the presentation down
and it's during the debate we do need to
go back so many of those images or plans
and of course we can but it's more
effective the debate if if we don't have
the presentation up all the time so that
we can all see each other so the
application and is for a new storage
building with a trackway and access it
is to facilitate better management of
the Dorner field camping and caravan of
sites and the red line and boundary
takes in the access way which goes from
one side to the other east to west
across the field and with the new
building being located in the northeast
top right
corner of the field it is proposed to be
located in a relatively discrete
location within the site and but as you
will note from the officer report there
are some significant concerns about the
landscape impact that this proposal
would have and we don't consider that
this is the right location for the
building given the land holding and the
sensitivity of this location and from a
landscape perspective and we note the
response from various constancies in
terms of the historic environment
response that we do consider that there
is a good planning reason why this
shouldn't gain permission and the site
is to the right of the large tree in the
field on the left of the lane this is an
image from Google Street View and so the
Google Street View car is slightly
elevated so that's not an entirely true
representation of what you would see at
the site but it gives you an idea of the
context of the area and and members will
note and the two stylistic buildings at
Dona Field just down the lane and and
that the recommendations and this one is
one of refusal as a consequence of the
impact of this proposal on the area
right thank you okay if I can ask John
Phillips now you have three minutes to
speak once you've started John can you
hear me most of all yes my name is John
Phillips of Luke's Planning and
Development I make this statement on
behalf of the owners of door field
camping partnership limited next factor
that has been circulated to all members
setting out the need for this building
our members have already visited the
site to assess the situation for
themselves had the invitation of the
owners the applications been thought
through very carefully from the outset
all the possible areas of the site could
be explored to assess their suitability
to accommodate this building but I know
other alternative locations which can
provide this facility with direct road
access to
the collection of waste and recycle
materials form the site the function of
the proposed building which is modest in
comparison to nearby agricultural bonds
is primarily for the storage of the
zucchini for the makers of the path
which extends the 38 acres this
equipment will account for 85% of the
internal storage whilst the remaining
15% would improve storage of waste and
recycle materials awaiting collection
the provision of the new building will
enable storage and servicing of the
machinery and collection of waste
appeals to be moved from the courtyard
area which is in close proximity to the
great to stylistic farmhouse and barn
and the collection of visitor entrance
buildings this will vastly improve
health and safety for those working at
the site and the many tourists staying
outside the owners in fact of the entire
area in an entirely responsible manner
aware of the various constraints were
proposed to your location the storage
building location would be entirely
hidden from the listed building and some
districts through the north by a
woodland belt you've also largely hidden
from you from born field name the
building would be entirely hidden from
the surrounding countryside and long
disabused from top this road which
appeared to be a concerned landscape
officer in this province
we've assessed this from the garden
center a long time this road and no such
long distant views are apparent there
are no objects is raised by historic
England the council's conservation and
Cree officers account the County
archaeologist County highways walk in
the parish council the only point of
issue is that of the landscaping
officers view and his earlier site visit
hands make through the landscaping
issues were significantly less than he
had anticipated and Burleigh
communicated to this to the applicant
mr. Zhu Hirst
subsequently his appraisal comments to
this report
do not accurately reflect what was
prudent discussed was taken at a time
that's like they did we believe that a
proper balance must be struck or whilst
landscaping object the landscape objects
that the local plan must be adhered to
we're irrelevant we believe in this
particular case they have been
overstated of the relevant issues other
policies which must be considered in the
terminus application to which there's
been little reference made include
positive ec 1180 12 s 2 s 12 these
positives in combination enable the
sustainable development of existing
tourist eternity
cunningham being part to enhance twist
site facilities important to the local
economy
the proposal provides the opportunity to
greatly improve site service but many
visiting tourists throughout the holiday
season and the operating needs of the
site we contended that proposal is
accessible on the positive car is going
to spectacle II asked members to support
application which will enable a
significant and much-needed improvement
in and the chair that time thank you
thank you scripts okay
there's nobody speaking objecting to
this so we've gone they'll not tell you
there's the Wold member is unable to
speak as he has an interest so I have
councillor McGregor has indicated speak
please Thank You chair and I was just up
at the the farm sorry up EpiPen at the
site on Saturday and Sunday I went I
went up on Sunday for an Indian not to
be shown around so that I would have a
better access in terms of some of the
policies that have been used to reject
the or to show that they contravene it's
very interesting that they chose s22
which is an attractiveness sustainable
settlements resilient rural economy etc
if you if you look at the the particular
site itself the actual whole site this
is a touring caravan site which has won
awards for best site in the country on
more than one occasion
it's absolutely immaculate I've never
seen anything like it I wish my wish my
lord looked like like all of the grass
in that area and it's a sustainable
settlement that there's employees that
base there all year round
wardens it's a it's a site that has you
know resisted the temptation to furlough
staff resisted temptation to to pay them
off so it's maintaining resilience
within the community the the actual site
itself where they are planning to put
the shed up it's around
on three sides by high hedges or by
trees it is 20 to 25 feet above the
level of the gray - listed building
which has two other buildings between it
and this site as well as a wooded
thickly wooded slope which covers what
used to be an old blame I mean in real
terms that there's no impact as far as I
could see on the great - listed building
at all the the actual building itself
that the new warehouse is going to be
shielded on definitely on two sides by
high trees from the front aspect the
allowing of a hedge to grow to a higher
height would prevent that being seen
from the scheduled monument across the
road in fact well actually you could
only see it from one of the mounds in
the scheduled Monument because there's a
ugly shared between the one of the
mounds or to the mounds and the and the
and the proposed development site so in
real terms looking up the elevation of
the land the the terrain you're not
going to see very much the actual field
itself compare that to the land around
the scheduled monuments it's lush
rolling grassland around the scheduled
monuments the actual field where this is
going to go is scrubby it's not very
pleasant it's a very very thin layer of
soil and grass over what looks like the
workings of the lime kiln the disposal
area so in reality there's not a huge
impact in terms of affecting the terrain
of the field
never mind a scheduled monument to the
other side of the road in terms of
impact I I don't see the I don't see it
in the same way as that the landscape
officer has seen it and I think to be
honest we I think this was one that in
terms of helping a local business which
not only maintains itself and its own
employees it maintains business in other
parts of the the area as well there are
several pubs and restaurants the
clientele that come there go and spend
money at the 2-mile in for instance and
in other locations across the a plain
area I I think I think this is a good
opportunity for this operation to tidy
things up not only for themselves but
actually in real terms for the whole
area and there are a number of sheds
around the area which are probably a lot
uglier and probably a lot more of an
eyesore in in terms of you know having a
look around the area so I would move
that we actually pass this application
as approved thank you alright so you're
moving approval well I can ask the next
speaker others to second that there are
some conditions that we might need to
consider if that's seconded we'll come
back to that short you know I've got
three people indicating to speak if you
keep points briefs please and not repeat
anything that's been previously said
councillor Nutley Thank You chairman I
think some of my points maybe was is but
I mean having read the Associated
documents for the application I decided
to take that site to visit to the site I
asked if I could see the present set up
used for the stories of the machinery
and the workshops and the storage of
waste these are in grade 2 listed
buildings with very little the storage
room with the various machinery required
to carry out the works around the
campsite I then went to the site where
the reposed building is to be built as
the plan shown it will be tucked away in
the corner of the film and will be
surrounded by mature trees and headings
I stood at the far end of the where the
proposed building will be see to see
what impact if any the rose building
would have on any neighboring properties
and the surrounding area I could not see
any properties from this point and could
only see some in the far distance across
totnes road when I stood far away in the
field access to the site would be from
the door third Lane and would be using
in his
entrance of the film's turret rack will
be used for the track way from the
entrance to the proposed building and a
further track way going from the post
building is the main caravan park would
be created using turf track this is an
order to gain access into the park which
alleviates having to used on the field
Lane by using to attract also means it
can be used for an OD construction and
will therefore protect the root system
of any trees in the area and is
supported by our TDC senior officer in
3.2 it mentions there is a sheduled
monument known as for burrows which are
in the fields opposite I was told there
are two mounds however these were not
very distinctive - and to me just like a
normal field as mentioned a three point
to the proposed building would be used
for storage of refuge recycle materials
and various machinery used in a caravan
and camping park in doing so would allow
all these to be used centralized in one
building taking the machinery out of the
grey - listed building and all the waste
and recycle was away from the courtyard
area in 3.9 it states that the proposed
building is located within open
countryside and any defined settlement
area this proposed building as I have
mentioned is tucked away in the corner
of a field and is not visible from the
camp site itself and the great - listed
building is all the properties in the
far distance this also this is also the
reason I have to disagree with thee when
it states in three points - it is an
elevated position I would also like to
point out that when driving to the site
I notice a very large temperature
structured barn far larger than the
proposed building elevated well above
the surrounding area and the Oakland
countryside in 3.19 I could were 1:9 I
cannot understand when it says there is
a possibility that the building will be
glimpsed from the totnes road the road
is at least half a mile away
as the crow flies
and if it was in the middle of the field
then yes there is the possibility and
certainly not by pedestrians or anyone
driving that should be keeping their
eyes on the road in 3.22 it is
acknowledged that the council's
conservation officer has not objected
the proposal it then goes on to say that
the National Planning policy framework
deeply defines the setting of a heritage
asset and that the proposed proposal
would erode the historic vernacular
setting of the great to start listed
buildings when the proposed building is
surrounded by mature trees and hedging
and and a wooded area you cannot see the
grade 2 listed buildings in responding
to 3 points 2 to 5 this is one of the
reasons for having the proposed building
to be able to store the refuge to
recycle Jews and the Paris machinery so
that the impact of noise and disturbance
on holiday matrice is further away in
3.26
Devon County came through archeology
Department have confirmed that the
submitted information is acceptable and
as such it is deemed as a proposed
proposal would not result in any adverse
impacts on the archaeology of interest
there seems to be a conflict of opinions
between DCC archaeologists and the TDC
conservation officer in 3.27 Devon
County gangs of Highways have raised no
objections to the proposal and 3.31
Devon County came to a mineral
department and the Devon stone
Federation have also raised no objection
proposed development also historic
England has no objections the
application on heritage grounds with
regards to the landscape assessment it
was originally proposed to have green
colored cladding which I would have
thought would blend in with the green
fields and surrounding trees and
hedgerows however it has been
recommended to have dark grey cladding
and a mid grade roof donor field caravan
park has been an award-winning park over
a number of years and is set in a
beautiful part of little pen it sits
adjacent to the grey
- listed buildings in Dornan field farm
over the years that has attracted large
numbers of tourists all of whom have
boosted a local comedy
it also gives employment at seven local
people including four who live on the
site I felt this as a sensible a
much-needed addition in helping the
operations of the caravan park and with
and with and with thought towards the
holidaymakers in allowing them to have
an enjoyable holiday with less noise and
disturbance I would therefore like to
second sensor McGregor's proposal and
second the application to it for
approval thank you thank you all right
got three others who wish to speak and
you keep the points brief now please I
think Johnson's giving us a detailed
critique of the report and we have some
others now councillor Keeling Thank You
mr. chairman and I won't labor on what
colleagues have said previously I
support this application also and I
support it basically because we need to
support business in our communities and
this is a business is is doing very well
and for them to actually not Furlong
their staff and pay them a hundred
percent of the wages that tells you a
lot about the business so I actually
support this I think we could actually
say that in s22 sustainable business
sustainable development for this
business and as our business manager
said at the start this would better
manage the actual area so I'm in support
of this Thank You mr. chairman thank you
Thank You chair just very briefly I
think councillor David Cox is still
waiting in the waiting room he's on the
phone so you may not be able to identify
him yeah he stay he stays in the waiting
room until the fourth up station which
they thought he's asked to speak thank
you very much okay I will let him know I
did declare an interest I would just
like to ask a couple of questions
I will not be voting on this application
although I would be supporting it the is
it usual to have the landscape officer
contradicting the conservation officer
in a conservation issue strikes me as
very strange and I'm a great fan of
having barns in natural colours in
countryside settings whilst this is
recommended to be gray it seemed
sensible to have it more countryside
colours rather than gray other than that
I will keep quiet and leave you to your
deliberations Thank You councillor Hugh
Cox before you come in councilors Cox
can I ask Rose Eastman if you wish to
respond to those questions raised as
them yeah sure thank you very much and
so there is good evidence and it's good
practice in landscape impact terms that
grey colors are more recessive in the
landscape than green so whilst it might
seem that green would be the appropriate
color actually gray blends better with
the wider landscape than green in most
instances which is why and we've
recommended that the material should be
green and I think in terms of the
conflict of opinion here that we've got
between conservation and landscape
advice they're looking at different
matters and and it is a planning balance
overall that's led us to our
recommendation of refusal so the
landscape officer is looking at the
protection of the landscape as a whole
taking into account the Heritage impacts
and the impact on the historic landscape
and that's his specialist area so yes it
is unusual for them to disagree and but
it's not unheard of and in this instance
the planning balance the officers felt
came down on the side of refusal and
we're absolutely not against the
principles of supporting this important
tourist destination we acknowledge the
role that it plays in the local
community and we think that storage is a
really good use for the bonds within the
historic complex the farm building and
that seems a sensible use so they are
barn fans are are by their very nature
very often storage buildings so we we
don't necessarily consider that isn't
their optimum viable use for those barns
so we're not we're not against the
enhancement of the facilities for this
site we just consider that on balance
this is not the right location for this
building we think that it would be too
prominent within the wider landscape the
experience when you drive between a pen
and Embree along this Lane is one of a
very quiet lane with almost no modern
interventions and we very recently been
dealing with concerns about the impact
on some trees in the locality as a
consequence of them some works towards a
residential property that's been in
existence for some time so it is very
sensitive to change this location is
incredibly sensitive to change and in
our view the even with the proposed
screening the levels in this area and
the the nature of this is very modern
very hard building would be such that
there would be an unacceptable impact on
the wider historic landscape in this
area but that is absolutely not saying
that we don't support this facility we
do support this facility we just don't
think this is the right location thank
you right County Cox yeah I'm not going
to repeat what everyone else has said
the only thing I noticed it is actually
shielded the site by trees on three
sides the hedge site by the road was
actually grown-up ash trees from a old
hedge line which would probably you have
to cut down at some point food fresh tie
back which would open up that view I
think if this went ahead they would need
to be a replanting scheme playing so
kind of cut off that does that make
sense
okay thank you thank you
council event thank you looking at the
application the principle behind
supporting a successful business I don't
think is in any doubt whatsoever that we
need to do that the issue
for me here is that a lots been spoken
about the tree screening the area of
course six months the year those trees
leaves their leaves and the view is
substantially change when you're putting
a building there which is two and a half
thousand square feet in floor area and
over 20 feet high it is a prominent
building and whilst I agree with the
principle that the site should have the
appropriate facility is not encouraged
the facilities to be put on site I'm not
certain that this is the right approach
for the site to take and I must admit I
support the offices of view here that
it is a prominent building in a location
when the trees lose their leaves can be
visible like most of us I've been around
I've been on the side streets I've seen
what it looks like so I support the
principle behind putting the appropriate
person is in place but I'm afraid oh you
have to agree with the offices here
though I think this particular design
would be inappropriate
thank you Thank You councillor I think
legal Paul you you've been indicating
you want to discreetly yes thank you
chair I just wanted to just remind
members that if they are minded to go
against officer recommendation that they
give clear reasons as to why they're
going to depart and also if they're
going to approve the the application and
what conditions in if any they they want
to apply to to that permission and
secondly chair if I may just a reminder
to to members that particularly those
who've declared an interest in one form
or another and then going to speak the
great caution should be should be had as
to words used so as not to be seen in
this particular case to influence those
making the decision Thank You chair
Thank You councillor Bradford Thank You
chair I wanted to ask Roz has there been
any surveys done on wildlife
on the on-site place
they're with me let me just pull up the
application file and I will be able to
tell you them I'm not sure that it's
something that we would necessarily
consider as essential on an application
of this scale in nature and in light of
the extent of the site that is being
lost and let me just have a look at what
we're submitting I note it is two and a
half thousand square feet which is quite
substantial and I think in in this
climate
emergency environmental emergency that
we should be doing a survey and seeing
you know if it's how much it's going to
affect the wildlife there yes thank you
cancel Abbasid no I can't see that any
biodiversity information was submitted
we have had a landscape statement come
in which may have addressed some of
those issues and to be fair to the
applicant I should note that they are
proposing solar panels on the roof but
that doesn't and since it's a you know
relatively low energy building has not
necessarily determinative one way or the
other and and obviously there would be
opportunities for Swift boxes or battle
birds but in life of the size and scale
I don't think that any biodiversity
information was necessary for this
application and but you're right in
there is a as part of climate emergency
making good use of existing buildings is
really important which is one of the
reasons why we think this would be
better located more in the heart of the
site possibly staying in and making good
use of the existing mr. buildings or
another location within the site I tend
to agree with you and I'm not averse to
the principle of the building but
I think it is just the wrong location
thank you okay thank you right I've got
nobody else indicated to speak we can
come back to the points that Paul from
legal gave us on page 17 of the report
members will note that there are
conditions that are should be attached
if the officer was minded to approve
from the landscape officer so you need
to look at those although the one that's
going to be potentially subject to
further debate is is the third bullet
point with the the color being
recommended gray my own view is that I
accept the point about the sort of
conflict between the landscape officer
and other heritage consultation offices
and the word glimpse from the top this
road I'm familiar with the area walk
around there certainly in the past not
recently so I wasn't particularly
bothered myself about the applications
impact and felt it would be acceptable
but I've been willing to go along with
the color recommended on page 17 so I
think I'm high disagree with some of
those other speakers we need to have
somebody indicating reasons or the
conditions that they're proposing and
why we're going against the officer
recommendation so if I had asked I think
counts and McGregor has indicated to
come back as the person who proposed the
approval
thank you chair just just a couple of
points to cover before I go to that
would be the site we'll be planting
along the hedgerow as councillor cops
rightly pointed out there is ash within
the hedge and the intent is to plant
evergreen holly trees along there to
provide the height necessary along the
roadside to obscure the shared the
building from the road completely you
will not be able to see it from the
scheduled monuments you'll struggle to
see it from from the main road with
those in place but they will take a
little bit of time of course to to
into maturity in terms of the color of
the the building I don't think that
would be an insurmountable problem for
the for the owners of the site I don't
think that's a huge issue for them at
all in terms of going against officer
recommendation in terms of policy en to
a the applicant has made every attempt
to minimize the visual impact of the
building within the local area and
that's one of the requirements of en 2a
so I think on that the the building is
of limited impact on the on the area it
is not going to have a permanent
disfiguring effect for a scheduled
Monument as indicated by the landscape
officer the landscape of the field
itself the character of the area is
already impacted by similar buildings
some of which are much more prominent
within the local area so I think in real
terms I think it's an it's a sustainable
settlement development its minimizes
visual impact and it fits with the
character of the area and that's what I
was saying okay so that's the reasons
why it's being approved contrary to
officer recommendation so which of the
conditions can I come back to Roz then
on the conditions that are shown on page
17 would would there be anything in
addition to that in the motion for
approval
yes there would M we would of course
want to make sure that we had a time
limit condition and an approved plans
condition and I would like to define the
use to make clear that this is a storage
building in association with the tourism
use that this is not an agricultural
building and as a consequence the
potential permitted development rights
that could accrue if we don't make that
clear
and we would also want to condition
compliance with the written scheme of
investigation that we have had in
relation to the archaeology works and
then the planting proposals or the other
landscape conditions to four conditions
that they're included I think it's at
3:17 or and in the page 17 sorry that
you were highlighting previously and I'm
not sure that a single species evergreen
hedge would be accessible I appreciate
that the landscape officer says it
should be an evergreen hedge but one of
the key characteristics if this local
area is the native species hedges that
are a mix of species and I the idea of
having to screen a building with an
evergreen hedge in this location is just
incredibly disappointing but I
appreciate the best the condition that
the landscape officer has indicated in
their comment thank you can ask proposed
and seconder if they are content with
those conditions but with the gray
building yes I think so I think in real
terms the the applicant is is content to
to work with the Planning officers on
the conditions being set a lot of the a
lot of the conditions are already in
mind for the applicant anyway and this
is an important development in terms of
helping that business move move safety
to the to the forefront as well because
it reduces the amount of traffic coming
through the site itself yes as far as
the conditions proposed to okay cancel
in that Lane second yeah thank you yes
I'm totally happy with that the only
reason I was saying about the green I
thought that blending in with the
countryside itself nothing really
against the gray just that I thought the
green would have been more appropriate
but happy to go along with the additions
yes okay thank you
right so
McGregor use till your hand up you need
to take that down don't think anyone
else that's not spoken this is now
wishing to speak so we have the motion
before us for approval with the
conditions as outlined by Rose Eastman
so I intend going to the vote on that
the motion is for approval conditional
approval so if I could ask Chris to go
through the members names and the either
vote for against or abstain please so
come counselor Bradford against
Chancellor Bullivant against councillor
Clarence for counselor cold cloth
[Music]
counselor Cox for LaHaye's Oh counselor
Jeffrey sounds like healing all
counselor Jenks I'm stuck as well
counselor MacGregor for counselor nettle
[Music]
stay counselor nutley for counselor
patch for counselor Parker for that's
the path rope or and deep that's
everyone sorry counselor Haines for and
counts the Goodman bradbury for
[Music]
[Music]
maybe that's eleven in favor three
against and one abstention
okay well I mean it's a majority of
voted for I had slightly more than that
I think the difficulty with hearing the
couple of them may have anything you'll
need to need to listen back through that
for the recordings of the votes but it's
certainly a majority with only three
against so that's carried and that's
been approved with the conditions as
outlined moving on then to the next
application which is in King's paintin
there's no public speakers on this one
so I don't have to wait for anyone to
join us so can I ask rose please to go
through the details of that sure I'll
just get myself to use presentation
again can you see my screen again if you
could confirm please yeah say that great
thank you so only before committee as
the applicant and is related to a member
of team bridge staff it seeks to bring a
small amount of land that borders a car
parking team Stainton within the
domestic intelligence property and
rather than it being part of the part of
the car park as you can hopefully see on
the block plan that's in front of you
now the distance between the building
and the current boundary on the site is
very small very narrow and it's a small
amount of land that they listen to bring
inside their curtilage there it's a
relatively minor change but it will
provide significantly better residential
amenity particularly around that that
side elevation of this property
the fence and structures that will be in
place are considered acceptable and it
will essentially move the defense line
that you can see in this image to the
back of the parking area there's no
impact on the parking area the parking
area stays the same size and there is no
loss of parking and so it's a it's a
fairly straightforward application and
will ensure that the fence and the
landscape area are kept and kept tidy
and and well maintained as opposed to
the situation as it has been when it's
been a neglected area of the site and so
it should have positive benefits for the
locality thank you neither of the ward
members indicated that they wish to come
along and speak the as you said the only
reason why it's on committee is because
of being something related to someone at
Cambridge so I'll be quite happy to move
but I notice we haven't got two people
who wish to speak so counsel John
Patrick please Thank You chairman yes I
think the application is entirely
reasonable and I would like to propose
that we approve the application that's
set out okay thank you and I've got
councillor Parker
Thank You counsel Haines yes I was going
to do exactly the same I do know the
area being to see it I think it tidies
up the area and I would happy second
approval as said oh thank you okay so
it's been moved and seconded for
approval as set out no other people have
indicated to speak apart from those who
have just spoken so in which case
without nobody else we'll go to the vote
then please so it's been moved for
approval as set out so you'll be voting
for against or abstain so if I could ask
Chris to go through the list again
please yep sir that's councillor
Bradford
fool constable oven for councillor
Clarence or answer cold cloth for
councillor haze a councillor hook
[Music]
councillor Jeffrey council aquiline all
councillor jinx sounds like as well poor
counselling MacGregor or ice then
that'll cancel Nutley and the patch for
answer Parker Thor asla Patrick for
councillor Wrigley Oh
councillor Haines for and councillor
Goodman Bradbury for so that's
unanimously in favor okay thank you so
that's approved as set out right if we
move on then to the next one which is
Bishop Stainton great - great furlong
can I just have it confirmed that the
objector and the supporter have joined
us in the meeting blazing tall we
proceed German they've been admitted to
the to the meeting so they should be
appearing soon
you
good morning Steven Adel for objection
yep and I think I can say Philip so is
down on the screen as well okay
in which case Rose can you do the
initial introduction please yeah sure
Thank You chair and again if you could
just confirm for me that you can see
icons right and super being great so -
great furlong has had a relatively long
standing history we've had a number of
applications at this site and we have
dealt with and the application that's
before us today is the retention of the
single story side extension and the
garage as built effectively and the you
can see that the site is and sand wedge
between two parts of great fair law and
and you'll see in the images if you if
you haven't already had a chance to have
a look with it is a relatively prominent
and property the recommendation from
offices is that if one of approval
there is no um no planning reason why
the these elements of the scheme should
not be taken forward should not be
approved in their current form and you
will note that there is a concern and
regarding the material and to the roof
and and that also we need to make sure
that Battenberg measures have been and
freely followed but essentially these
are relatively minor works and to an
existing property and they were
undertaken not in not fully in
accordance with approved plans in
relation to previous scheme so this is a
revised scheme there has been approval
for various iterations of this this
project previously and but there are no
planning reasons why this proposal in
its current
form it's not acceptable and of course
if you want me to go into the detail of
any of that I can and hopefully you can
see from these images and plans and that
there is no unexpected impact on the
street scene or on residential munity
and of any of the adjoining and occupies
those and yes no reason to not grab this
plan of mission from the officer's
viewpoint I hope that happens can I just
ask a question then before I ask the
public speakers in the update sheet you
here's the thing where they're actually
requesting about the materials could you
just clarify that for me please yeah
sure so that we in our condition and
we've suggested that the as-built
extension the roof should be changed to
match the host property and the
applicant has understandably raised a
concern about that because of the
disturbance and the disruption as well
as the cost that would arise as a
consequence of that change and so and
they are proposing that it should be
left like it is as opposed to being
changed to and the browner rougher
material as we have suggested it should
be to make your cities a better match
for the surrounding properties in
grateful okay because that that clearly
is one of the conditions recommendation
existing isn't recommend its condition
to isn't it yeah right okay so members
need to be mindful of that that's in the
update in the report all right thank you
if I could now introduce the members of
the public who are speaking and asked
them they had each of you have three
minutes on this application so it's
Stephen Mable first place if Stephen
could appear and then times would start
you're Monica can you hear me okay
yes thank you okay so I should begin
I've been asked by my parents neighbors
to summarize our collective objections
to
retrospective planning application
hopefully all receive my email on Sunday
illustrating with pictures issues we
feel on communicated effectively with
text alone
or concerned center around two themes
namely a tough out of character design
and planning president's residents
concerned the officers report skims over
the significant increase in dimensions
of the garage as builds this is now over
30 percent higher than previous
application with the ridge line of fall
one point three five meters taller than
the original rejected application it's
clearly has a negative impacts on both
the street scene and outlook from
neighbors both to north and south and
could have been easily mitigated by
digging foundations deep enough and
constructing a garage of usable size and
in accordance with previous plans the
Planning Officers report approving a
previous application it stated that on a
quote the bulk viewed from the north
which will be screened by the existing
fence will also be reduced by this
revised scheme the garages build is
almost 1 metre higher and longer than
plan is not shielded by the fence and
has a far greater impact than any
previous scheme to be consistent this
application must be rejected we've now
been waiting well over a year for
enforcement action initially neighbors
were told this was unlikely as though
it's claimed that dimensions were close
to those accepted under permitted
developments however with this latest
application the true height of the
garages built has finally been conceded
to be the same height as the main house
and fall well outside the scope of
committed developments great pain has
been taken over the 30 years since the
estate was developed to maintain
consistency and to protect our look at
properties both my team regime bishops
Danes in parish council presidents say
historically projecting applications
similar to one being considered today
sent around a principle to maintain not
quite planners the open character and
appearance of the surrounding area and
to avoid an unreasonable precedent for
similar developments and which results
in the unreasonable loss of outlets the
neighboring property not only this
application fly in the face of this
presidents but its use of external
support structures out of character
materials and a roof pitched 10 degrees
lower than anywhere else in great
furlong make it questionable how
planners will be able to maintain the
uniformity in character at the area
going forward should this plan be
approved the playing officer's report
omits concerns about the use of a smooth
render on the garage extension in north
base of the house following the
relocation of the front door properties
in great furlong an original part number
to itself make use of the textured
Alpine render use of consistent render
was condition of the previous
application and the current use was
smooth highly reflective render not only
looks out as a place but heightens
impacts bright lighting at night
in summary the application for you must
be declined on the grounds of presidents
in Congress design this impacts on
neighbors is now significantly greater
than the original rejected on appeal
application neither the parish council
nor local residents support this
application we finally know that they've
been sufficient of misleading
representations in the numerous
applications that any costs on appear
unlikely to be awarded against team
bridge like thank you all for your time
you give right if I could now ask for
Philip Berman please - this is three
minutes
you
you
you
I owe you for that
you're muted and can't see can you could
you unmute him Chris all right sorry
it's my end yep okay got you now then
right so your three minutes will start
when you start down on them okay all
right good morning my name is Philip
Rumson and the first thing I want to say
is I agreed with the planning officers
report and appreciate this is Bouvier's
detailed answers on every point this is
the second time she's been through it
and it must have been quite an effort to
do that so we appreciate her effort so
this application is to cover two
amendments to the original consent and
the two to changes are to delete the
proposed kitchen conservatory extension
this means the back of the house will
essentially be unchanged and the second
one is because of ground conditioners on
the foundations the height of the garage
turned out slightly higher but we've
mitigated this by reducing the width now
just to put this into context the the
footprint of the garage is slightly less
than the standard model of garage my
neighbor's having great drilling and the
height as you can see from the third row
actually just is only two thirds of the
height of everybody else's couraged so
it's a much smaller garage the
construction has been proved today have
been approved to date by the building
inspector and we had a survey carried
out to which you have a copy to
demonstrate that the extensions are
compliant with the planning code so the
next thing I wanted to discuss is this
issue the tiles just wanted to show you
this this is one of the old tiles that
came off the roof it's been heavily
weathered but you can see the original
texture until the towel this is a
Redland stone walled sleigh
a concrete tile this is what Baathist
was on all the houses when they built
them this is a new redolent stone walled
slate gray concrete tile and this is
what you can buy today the builders
merchants it's the same material and the
same color now the reason why the the
tiles are different at the moment and I
can look out the window here and there's
two other extensions that were built
about the same time the reason they're
slightly different right now is the
weathering and what we what we want to
do to make sure is that the new tiles
whether to look like their existing
tiles and there's plenty of examples
around the estate the the extensions
that were built 15 to 20 years ago and
there's a house immediately in front of
mine they're roof tiles on the extension
now look like the main house so given
that the outlook and the architecture of
great it's extremely important I think
that we make sure all the tiles and all
the materials are matching and have a
common theme thank you thank you
right before I bring in the Wold member
can I just ask perhaps for some
clarification on that point from Rawls
as far as the the color of the tiles and
matching is concerned and the sort of
weathering aspect of it and how the
wording perhaps could be adjusted to
enable that to happen
thank you - so if I can just have a look
at the condition that we've put in the
recommendation and I think what we
should put in there is that the roof
materials must match and that we would
request submission of evidence that they
do and if they don't that they need to
be replaced so I think that we can cover
off both scenarios and through using a
condition slightly reworded from that
that's in the recommendation at the
moment to make sure that we get the
right materials I appreciate the point
that's being made by the okay so the
wording would vary okay um council
occurs well I've seen you weighed in but
we're in the middle of sorting that to
do wishing to speak can speakers are
several no doesn't can you hear me
counsel occur as well
she's not muted that is whether the
sound on the laptop is perhaps muted I'm
not sure if that has an effect on it
could somebody try and contact her
Council McGregor waving of it I have put
up happen up a note saying it's here we
did the gate by sign language but
doesn't appear to be responding so
what's going on there
it sounds like she's obviously not muted
but is unable to to hear or speak
we're trying one of us would try and get
hold of her will will progress but it
means that sure she's not been hearing
it she won't be able to vote on this one
when the eventually resolved yet okay
councillor McGregor would you like two
speakers ward member Thank You chair um
I haven't really got much to say on this
it's it's been a it's been an
application and and issue that I've been
aware about aware of since it's becoming
a ward councillor in there is quite
clearly a lot of concern amongst
residents around the property about the
look and feel of the area I can you know
I can hear you now
councillor Kurzweil can you hear me now
I would imagine it it's a problem with
the device sorry councilman great go to
continuum yeah so in real terms here you
know I'm aware it's caused quite a lot
of firstly it's been backwards or
forwards in terms of discussions between
the Planning Committee Bishop state to
parish council a planning planning
department in in team bridge and there's
been quite a number of concerns raised
by by residents living around I
understand
mr. Emerson's position
about the you know changes in designs
and also know that he has provided it
was very difficult to see on 40 with the
size of the screen but very difficult to
see the tiles but in in real terms
if the tiles are the saying product then
there will be weathering over a period
of time I I don't think it would be
reasonable to expect mr. Emerson to go
out and find weathered pre weathered
tiles specifically just to match in
early one thing that has raised the
concern that hasn't been addressed so
far is the external finish of the of the
buildings in terms of the the rougher
Alpine finish on to the smoother texture
of the finish that's on the current
property I'm not sure whether that's
something that has been considered by
Ross so hopefully she'll be able to to
answer that but I would I would just say
that in considering this application
that you take account of the concerns of
local residents thank you okay thank you
right anybody else wishing to speaker I
can certainly give my view on it I feel
that from what I've seen from the images
and looking at the previous application
on file I am content with the effect of
it on the surrounding areas provided
that the the colors match as far as one
can the existing material so that's why
I was concerned about that condition
okay I've got councillor Ridley wishing
to speak Thank You chair I'm always
worried when things are built that don't
comply with the planning permission that
they were given and I think that in
itself is a situation that we should be
concerned about if a situation arises
where you cannot construct what you're
trying to build within the limits of
your plan
mission you should go back and talk to
the planners and get it sorted and make
an agreement rather than continue and
build it anyway I think counsel mcgregor
makes a very good point I also find it
very interesting looking at the photos
supplied by Steven Mabel by email gives
a very different view from the photos
that we have in the offices report and
the thing I find absolutely jarring to
my eye when looking at that is the
different roof pitch it just looks like
a a sore thumb from that angle
that's not an angle that we were
supplied with in the report this is a
very difficult thing to judge from the
limited photographs and limited bits and
pieces that we have I know that for the
past few months we've not been able to
do site visits but this might be a case
where a site visit might be a good way
forward to actually get a better view of
it on site to walk around it to look at
it to see how much of an impact the
different finish really does have and
see how much of an impact the different
roof angle has and the height and to
take a view ourselves on the tiles
because in the pictures they do look
different they do look different sizes
it's hard to tell but we hear from the
applicant that they are the same size
and the same the same tiles themselves
so it's difficult to know without
actually going and having a look and
seeing it so I think it's unusual for me
not to be decided on these things having
seen the evidence but I think a site
visit might be called for in this case
and I see from guidance that we are now
able to do site visits again so I would
like to propose that we do a site visit
to determine this application thank you
can I ask if anyone is beckoning that
perhaps somebody may wish to when they
speak in the moment we can do site
visits up to six members this was sent
out to explain to members how this can
be done
okay councillor Jackie Hooke
making change whilst I recognize that
this set of proposals has a long
planning and enforcement history I'm
feeling that I need to judge you on what
I see now and the level of any effects
that I see visually or I'm told that
there is in terms of dimensions etc and
when I judge it against that I have to
say I am not offended and I believe the
planning officer recommendation strikes
the right balance including the change
to the wording suggested this morning so
I'll just leave it at that I'm content
with the recommendation as set out thank
you um did you wish to move approval
yeah that's it hell I set out with that
slight amendment that Roz went through
because of the roof materials right
second that so that's the motion that's
before as if site visit is secondly then
that will become the amendment cancer
John Patrick know each other
I was about to settle in because of the
hooks
okay thank you so that's been seconded
did anyone wish to second counselor
Wrigley's site inspection which would
then become an amendment cans macaques
because the hulex
yeah there's no coming from can you hear
me now
yep okay all right our second counselor
please site visit okay thank you
so that's the amendment because it
hadn't been seconded prior to the
children I set out with the variational
materials anyone else wish to speak
nobody else's hand raised so take those
off then counselling [ __ ] in which case
we'll have these two votes here the
first vote will be on the amendment the
amendment is for a site visit so if I
could hand over to Chris please for the
amendment a site visit on this
application can i yes can I just add
because I Perl didn't hear the debate
rules counselor castles rejoin the
meeting but because she didn't hear all
other bait we won't be calling her name
for for voting okay
over to you Chris plays for site
inspection okay so cancer Bradford for
cancer Bullivant against councillor
Clarence against cancer Cole cloth
against Chancellor Cox
Chancellor Hayes gauged counselor
counselor Jeffrey counselor Keeling
the Jencks okay counselor McGregor or
Council for counseling Nutley or
counselor patch for counselor Parker
against cancer Patrick against counselor
wriggly Oh counselor Haines against and
counselor Goodman bribery for okay
so that's turn IV let's turn in ten
against nine in favor that is what I
recorded I have recorded nine that for
ten against of that is lost in which
case we come back to the original
proposal which was it be approved as set
out but with the slight variation on the
materials condition that was outlined
okay so if we could go through a roll
call again again counselor Kurzweil
unable to vote so it's the emotion is it
be approved
okay so counselor Bradford I'd say
constable event or counselor Clarence
bolt cancel the Copa Paul counselor
o'clock abstain counselor Hayes counsel
sounds legit every oh I'm Sookie healing
all counselor shanks for comes from the
Kroger against that's an actual okay
cancel Nutley
that's the patch against councillor
Parker for counselor
Patrick or can strictly against
councillor Haines and counts Goodman
Bradbury abstain
[Music]
and see if there's any of unda screaming
so I believe it's 10 in favor five
abstentions and three against I made it
11 in favor three abstention sorry five
abstentions and three against okay so
majority that is carried it is approved
as set out with that slight variation on
conditions and materials thank you
right so we're moving on now to the next
one which is writing D Timnath we need
to have the supporter Chris Cunningham
into the meeting and also councillor
David Cox into the meeting as well so if
we could just verify those and have them
I take it everything is okay now and
you're back with us counselor as well
yeah I'm see you nodding right I think
you see Chris Cunningham there and Kathy
David Cox on this thing I noticed he's
killed me chair just bear with me two
seconds okay chair we've we've have
someone connecting with councilor iPads
so I think that's probably David Cox
it's connecting to audio at the moment
counselor Cox David Cox see you out
there I'm here all right yeah I could be
I can see you now as well and I can see
we've got Chris Cunningham in as well so
we can we can move on now so if I could
ask Rose please to reduce this item the
landrum are great you can take your hand
down there
I can see in the screen rats but I can't
see you
great thank you and good and I internet
was glitchy there for a second so great
and so this application is an
application for replacement dwellings in
Timnath overlooking childen bridge and
you'll see in the recommendation that
there are a number of conditions that we
propose that go along with this in a
sense relating to making sure that the
application that we've got is is
implemented and so there's some I'm
really useful drawings on this slide
package I want to make sure that you've
all seen and in particular the there's a
couple in here that show a comparison
between the existing dwelling up that's
on site and the proposed dwelling and
the keys I think it's sometimes quite
difficult to understand and the scalar
and nature of the proposals for
replacement railings like this so this
is one of the first ones I wanted to
draw your attention to you hopefully
will be able to see the red dotted
outline which shows the footprint of the
existing built development on site and
you can see that the proposed new
dwelling largely fits with inside that
outline there are some discrepancies as
a more useful garage proposed and a
slightly greater width to the southwest
side of the dwelling but largely the
footprint is is very similar to that of
the existing dwelling that's on site and
similarly it's harder to see on this
drawing and but hopefully you'll be able
to see the pitched roof outline of the
existing dwelling and then you can see
the extent of the dormer windows and on
the existing dwelling as well on the
side elevation here and you can see that
the the height of the proposed dwelling
is in large part within if not lower
than the existing roofs cape and the
awesome elevation here the southeast
elevation shows the hipped roof the
sloping roof angles of the existing
dwelling and you can see the corners of
the proposed dwellings and protruding
beyond that to the sides but and broadly
you can see that the proposed dwelling
fits within the envelope of the existing
dwelling on site and some floor plans
showing the the scale and layout of the
scheme and then we've got some
photographs that show the existing
elevations so you can see there the
dormer window and the gables and so the
roof slope of the proposed dwelling was
within that overall envelope of seeing
that and then this the site is the
middle of these three dwellings so you
can see that they all three and have a
different design aesthetic there's a
flat roof dwelling to the left this
swelling which is sort of a Chalet style
bungalow and then the sea and slightly
more villa style dwelling to the right
and that's a view sort of a view taken
from the Sheldon and bridge traffic
lights and the next two images show a
comparison of the view from the existing
to the proposed and you can see from the
right-hand image the modest nature the
discrete nature of this proposal the way
that it fits in a very quiet manner in
the street and as those the existing
dwelling it doesn't have a particular
presence in the streets so it's not not
a building but from the in between drive
approach and would certainly be missed
in terms of any urban design reasons why
the building would be required to
terminate the view those sorts of things
so the view is terminated by a few of
the nests which is you know obviously a
pleasant natural outlet from the site
and then this is the view from Sheldon
Bridge again you can see the proposed
new dwelling fitting well in between its
neighbors there's the different design
aesthetics of the various dwellings
hopefully that's a adequate Whistlestop
obviously as previously we can come back
to these images if we need to during the
discussion all right thank you so if I
could now ask mr. Chris Cunningham to
crisis please three minutes okay morning
chairman councillors I'm a little
surprised that this application has been
referred to this committee given there
aren't actually any objections at all to
the proposed design in fact we've
received nothing but positive comments
about this including from a number of
timber town councillors the existing
building itself has perhaps politely
best described as being a building of
little architectural quality or
significance it sits in a line of large
detached houses all of the varying
periods and contrasting architectural
styles fall in between immediately to
the west is a very distinctive
flat-roofed Art Deco style building was
one field lured to the east with its
doubled fronted gable bait Windows is
completely different
there is no overriding established
pattern or style to fit in with here the
site is neither within a conservation
area or immediately adjacent to any
listed buildings but though it can be
seen from Sheldon Bridge and in context
to the old Toll House both which are
listed but this is no different to the
present building the site is however in
a prominent position at the gateway to
Timnath and can be clearly seen both
from close up crossing the British and
Sheldon particular winds are queuing in
the traffic and from the wider view
points around the estuary we see this as
an opportunity the proposal is to
demolish the existing and to replace it
with a new house with excellent
eco-friendly credentials whilst an
appropriately contemporary design it is
designed to be sensitive to the location
and to be a high quality and attractive
addition to the townscape the size of
the proposed building is modest and
appropriate by digging in the lower
floor and using a shallow pit roof we
have substantially reduced the overall
high compared to the existing external
materials were taken a natural partner
and the building will nestle comfortably
into the landscape making a quiet
statement of quality and individuality
but without being pretentious or with
any in
appropriate bling in this way we're join
the growing number of high quality
individual contemporary houses located
in prominent locations around the tina
story all of which integrate very
successfully into their surroundings as
a final point I would ask you to
consider what an interesting and
attractive building in a prominent
location like this says about Timnath
and Sheldon as with other similar
projects that events are undertaken
including teen heritage and salt house
in particular I believe it clearly
demonstrates that Timnath and children
are forward-looking and progressive and
doing so we believe it provides a real
boost for the area we request therefore
that you follow the clear officer
recommendations to support this
application which will allow a
long-standing local family to build a
new house here for their own occupation
thank you thank you okay so councillor
David Cox has asked two speakers Ward
members so there were cheering council
Cox
why can you hear me yeah yeah very much
I would fully support this application
the our cadet has done a good job here
he's in fact it's a lower profile than
the original building which the 1920s
built on the state of Frank caught a
Milford who was a great philanthropist
the timber but he basically sold his
plots of his of the in between estate
and you have completely different
properties all along it fits in nicely I
think it will be positive for Timnath
and as I say good local architect not
someone from London coming down with a
grandiose design suitable property and I
would hope the committee would
unanimously support this is to be
commended and it fits in nicely with
that and on my drive to team bridge
among my drive to timberland bridge I
will look at it and I'm sure I'll be
very happy with it
so I would strongly support the strongly
support this proposal and hope the
committee will you Nana misleading right
thank you I've also had an email sent to
Trish from councillor Sylvia Russell and
she supports the application so that's
another team member okay I've got
councillor McGregor indicated to speak
Thank You chef I'm live in Timnath
although my ward is next door and I
looked at this this particular
application with a huge sense of relief
actually it's a very positive
development it's at the end of the
bridge it really kind of almost says
Gateway environment to tin with itself
Timnath has a huge variety of
architectural styles from folly castles
right down to you know very small
roadside cottages you know from like
from my perspective this is a beautiful
design
it reflects very very similarly to the
replacement building that's going for
the Admiralty House on the other side of
the the the estuary at the Ness and I
think it's perfectly within the keeping
of the of the area it's within the
architectural you know sensibilities if
you like of developing an area
sensitively and I think you know as
councillor Cox has pointed out it does
it does look like an attractive building
when you're coming across the bridge
there and on that basis I would move
that we grant the the permission on this
one and and we we get a beautiful
development going as quickly as possible
thank you very much the conditions
recommendation yes Thank You councillor
John Patrick Thank You chairman I think
Carolyn McGregor beat me by a few
milliseconds because I was happy to
actually propose I said so I'm happy the
second cancer than the Gregor's proposal
thank you very much
okay council counts
Chris you're muted still
you
nope yeah I'm with you now softly so
about that yeah fully fully supported
Chris coming hams
work on this he's done a really
first-class job I know the building well
the late Frank Howard used to live in
there and I was in that building 45
years ago trying to get the pump to work
in the cellar there's some underground
water there and it's a way of pumping it
out so no the old building well they
said no architectural merit at all and
this will be a good statement he's done
a good job there and agreed totally
agree with councillor David Cox from
those that have spoken already it's sort
of pudding Timnath on the map was
reference to shorten their salt house
which is one that Chris Cunningham
designs Admiralty House was just
mentioned that's another statement of
21st architecture it wasn't actually
done by that one by Chris Cunningham but
another architect who that one in a
similar vein to what Chris coming ups
done so okay let's think they'll do it I
say thank you right can i next speakers
unless it's particularly and any other
point if you could keep them brief
counsel in event thank you if you look
at item eight the community
infrastructure levee the proposed gross
internal error is 394 square metres go
back to item 3.1 it talks about the
existing structure being a two-story
structure and the plans that we saw show
their two-story structure at almost
identical footprint to the modern new
plans
how is it that the community
infrastructure levee calculation implies
that there's a doubling floor area when
the plans don't show it the description
of the existing house doesn't show it
okay I guess that's a technical point
I'm just having a quick look at it on my
laptop there it's not possible of
elimination it is something that can be
clarified butter where the Ross can give
us a straight answer on that Ross well
having a quick look at the plans that
we've got and I haven't been involved in
a calculation with that some for me by
colleagues but we
do you have a substantially bigger
garage area which will be included
that's chargeable floor space and and
there will be a difference between the
area that's within the roof there's
probably because this is a so on to a
better phrase a keyboard building and as
opposed to some kind of trippy Zoid
shape and there will be an increase in
usable floor area so it's likely to and
have an impact and there in any event if
the applicant is genuinely a self
builder felicity misses and we would
expect and anticipate that they would be
claiming Salford exemption so whilst
there might be an increase in the floor
space and we would not necessarily
expect that we would collect that so if
the property is self built and if the
relevant notices I served on us and at
the the right time so there is a
significant still liability and I guess
it's part of the reason so it's a season
to redevelop the site is to get a
different configuration and but that is
as we say a technical point I can make
sure that we absolutely get that clear
before we issue in it okay thank you
very much all right counselor jackie
hook i just wanted to express my
surprise at this reached planning
committee to write this comprehensive
report the to ward councillors are in
favor there's various letters of support
that i can see i think we as members
need to be careful about what we're
calling into the committee because
there's potential for a lot of time to
be wasted valuable time of our planners
well if you look at the report it was
the town council that actually called it
in and that's a recent change that we
made so members might wish to look at
that ongoing a change we made to things
being called to committee alright Chris
you've already spoken up and cash your
hands too up so I think everyone who
wish to speak has spoken so we can go
for the vote on this now it's
and it's been moved and seconded the
recommendation with those five
conditions so can I go
Chris please can you take vote please
it's it's been recommended it's approved
so you'll be voting for against or
abstaining okay comes the barefoot ball
council Bullivant
for that's the clown's or comes a cold
cloth councillor [ __ ] saw the haze
[Music]
comes the hook poor also Jeffrey council
Aikido for
councillor Jenks occurs well poor
Council McGregor oh I'm not oh oh
councillor Nutley more councillor patch
or councillor Parker so John Patrick for
councillor Wrigley or councillor Haines
for and councillor Goodman Bradbury all
this does you know honesty in favor yep
I'll make that unanimous 20 votes in
favor
now again so that's carrying that's
approved right if we move on then to the
next application which is yielding t'n
and the Holloway should be joining us
plus we've got two objectors and a
support and so we've got Richard Ray
Simon kiri
and Ian Roach - need to confirm that
most of all join this place right
Seanna Simon Kaylee hello I've got him
here Roch them as well yeah got Simon
Kaylee and we're just looking for
Richard gray who is shown muted Richard
a well I think yep okay so we'll we're
all here
so what I'll do I don't know whether
Richard and Simon you've decided who
which of the two of you is going first
but I'll ask Hannah to do the interview
know sort of take us through the slides
before we before we do that so Anna can
you start off please Thank You chair
this is an application for outline
Planning Commission for a mix of office
and light industrial general industrial
and storage and distribution units
approve the sort for access and
landscape details with details of
appearance layout and scale being
reserved masses the application form
states a total of 40,000 square meters
of floor space and the delivered
developing areas plan which will go to
next shows a area of 4.1 hector's the
total site area of six point six eight
sectors as the development area the
remaining space would be a wetlands
flood area and a dark fat flight
corridor adjacent to lift and Brooke
this is located Jason to the little
lived in Business Park and the access
would be of the lifting road to go to
the next plan you have the access detail
oh no sorry we have the landscape
details which shows the flood area then
the next plan chase this is the access
details including an uncontrolled
crossing across the road there to the
footpath on the other side which has the
requirement of the
County highways team the officer
recommendation is to approve outlined
consent subject to the condition set out
in the report Thank You chair okay thank
you I think what some photos as well oh
yeah well this has been sent out to
members and there will be other pictures
of members have seen as well yeah so
this is the this is the site you can see
Tragos in the background on the other
side the Deaf expressway
that's the round that's the footpath
along the road
that's just another view of the site and
there you have the 30 mile-an-hour fine
you can just see that on that photo and
the access would be the other side of
that okay finish yeah thank you thank
you so is it going to be Simon or
Richard that's going first I think it
was going to be me first Richard is that
Richard okay so each of the two of you
had five minutes because it's a major
and then we've got me supporter Ian
Rocha will be speaking not ten minutes
so don't you Richard good morning
I'd like to start by saying that in view
of the lockdown own to the Kobe 19
pandemic we've all come to appreciate
the things in life the money can't buy
most of us on our daily walk have
noticed the birdsong the wild flowers
and the sound of animals do we really
want to lose this we have a local plan
for development designed to protect our
environment and this application is not
in that plan and if it was approved it
will take away the joy of living in a
rural setting on this basis I'd like to
expand on a few relevant points firstly
the size of the proposed development and
its proximity to nearby housing will
completely destroy the rural character
of libertine which is designated a rural
village by Tim bridge district council
in the 1970s it was necessary to build
the own 38 to divert all unnecessary
traffic away from towns and villages
this proposal will be a complete
reversal of that intention causing air
noise and light pollution the outcome of
which will be an increase in physical
and mental illness among the residents
who chose to live in a quiet village on
the basis of the low
plan increased heavy goods vehicle
traffic would affect not only liver turn
but also picking ttan endangering both
life and property I speak from
experience as someone whose home was
severely damaged owing to a 38 tonne
concrete pump operating out the existing
business park overturning and smashing
into the front of my house thankfully
this happened at 6:15 a.m. a bit later
the pavement would have been full of
schoolchildren a few months after this
incident
another large vehicle mounted the
pavement on the corner of Benedict Road
gouging the pavement and damaging the
curb parents are also worried as the
pavement leading to Blackpool school is
extremely narrow and at drop-off and
pickup times the traffic is parked nose
to tail along the road making the
roadways markedly reduced this coupled
with the school being situated at the
base of a steep hill on a blind Bend
makes extra heavy goods vehicle traffic
a real hazard never to pavements are
always busy with pedestrians apart from
school times we have many dog walkers
and people walking to the post office
please reflect on how we'd feel if this
plan was passed on economic grounds
alone and someone got killed as a result
surely if we're going to have a progress
it should benefit the whole community
this proposal this proposed development
is always referred to as a Business Park
it should read Industrial Estate b1 is
heavy industrial b2 is light industrial
on ba is storage and distribution a
Business Park
conjures up clean tidy office units the
reality is heavy industry is that
appropriate for a rural village noise
from heavy goods vehicles is a
particular concern for the residents
buildings actually vibrate many also do
not adhere to the speed limit of course
another great concern finally there's
evidence of otters living in libertine
brothel which is adjacent to the
proposed site I'm sure you're aware that
otter habitat is protected by law and
he's sure to be affected by ongoing
noise and light pollution and runoff
into the brook especially at times of
flooding the existence I had extensive
flooding miss February 2020 how sad it
would be to lose one to the wildlife we
have in the relentless pursuit of
economic gain in conclusion this
proposal is certainly of no benefit to
the local population and violates the
local plan for living on the basis of
which many residents chose to the
village as their homes thank you thank
you okay moving on then to Simon Kaylee
good morning good morning I'm a
chartered surveyor with over 30 years
experience in commercial property I and
my family have lived in Libertines for
the last 14 years having moved from
Bobbie Tracy so that our three children
could walk to Blackpool school
Libertines was a pleasant and safe place
to live I would like to focus on some of
the objections previously expressed on
this application demonstrating need is a
fund is fundamental to satisfying the
requirements for an exception site the
applicant has provided no evidence
themselves of need listed for this
development relying instead on the
figures within the adopted plan I am
skeptical about the level of demand for
business base as stated in the local
plan if demand is truly at levels
indicated the various extant permissions
in the area would have been brought
forward already there are three such
sites within five miles of the
application site each readily accessible
from the a38 this does not include the
form of BCT site where work is now
commenced the absence of underlying need
means that should live it and be
developed it is likely to be to the debt
heath field Industrial Estate the new
development will draw existing tenants
from Heath field leaving behind them
redundant buildings something which is
likely to be made worse by the economic
downturn arising from coronavirus such
property churn does not correspond to a
net increase in jobs within the area
I suggest the long-term gain in
employment from this development as
stated by the applicant is optimistic to
say the least the local plan identifies
the importance of suitable highway
infrastructure when considering an
exception site such as this the MPP F
stresses that cycling foot traffic
should be prioritized over motor
vehicles at points the carriageway width
to the site is only six and a half
metres not the nine metres as stated in
the applicants supporting information
insufficient to accommodate two lanes of
traffic plus a safe cycle space the
applicant is relying on data concerning
traffic flows around drum bridges from
2017 more recent planning applications
in Newton abbess and elsewhere suggest
that vehicle movements around drum
bridges are likely to increase
appreciably above those levels
anticipated when the road infrastructure
of drum bridges to Heathfield Industrial
Estate was upgraded no similar
improvements were made to the slip road
to libertine as it was considered a
minor Road additional traffic on this
road including significant numbers of
lorries arising from the proposed
development were result in further
congestion at what is already a busy hub
other applications currently under
consideration by this council and double
national park authority unlikely towers
significant impact on traffic flows
through the village and onto the
roundabout at drum bridges such
additional traffic flows are not
considered fully in the consultant's
report or seemingly by the highway
Authority in their analysis and
recommendations here I am particularly
concerned at the potential adverse
impact on amenity including physical and
mental health of residents from this
development
criterion D of policy s1 relates to
health safety and environmental effects
from any development including those
from Associated traffic these do not
believe that these issues might be
effectively controlled by incorporating
conditions into any consent even at
outline stage they will not may I remind
members that such conditions are
discharged without public consultation
similar conditions for operating hours
to those envisaged here were included in
the consent for the existing business
park in Libertines in 2018 also owned by
the applicant in my view the protection
that should have been afforded to
residents by that condition has been
abused and as a result all those tenants
are able to operate legally seven days a
week and the majority of those 24 hours
a day the proposed development has the
potential to cause real harm to
residents and the wider community the
development is out of proportion with
the size of the village and adversely
affects its character in relative terms
to Newton Abbot it is greater than
building an industrial estate on the
racecourse so bear that in mind the
economic benefit from this development
will extend little further than to the
developer and those involved in
constructing it that is no reason to
grant consent it is my hope that members
of the council will see fit to reject
this application thank you thank you now
if I can ask Ian Roche please you've got
10 minutes support of the application
thank you chair can you hear me firstly
yes thank you very much so good morning
everybody my name is Ian Roche and I'm a
planning consultant based in Timnath I
act on behalf of the applicant mr. Ben
knock who is a team bridge resident
business owner and employer and I
address you today in support of this
application our key message is that this
application can make an extremely
positive difference to the economy of
team bridge by boosting the supply and
delivery of employment land which
in short supply and in high demand
employment land equals jobs there is a
jobs gap in team bridge which in other
words means we have lots of residents
who commute out of the district every
day to do their work we've also had some
businesses leave the district to
relocate elsewhere and as mentioned
there have been business closures and
notably British ceramic tiles last year
this needs to be addressed by provision
of new employment opportunities within
the district you'll be very aware of all
the new homes that are being built but
there's been substantially less
construction of employment development
we need jobs as well as homes the corona
virus pandemic and the major economic
downturn it's surely leading to only
make this more imperative not less we
need to give the economy every
opportunity we can to get back on its
feet let's look at some numbers for a
moment the local plan allocates
employment land sites and seeks to
deliver 12 thousand square meters of
employment floor space every year
however as the council has itself
conceded in public published figures the
allocated sites are not delivering and
have limited prospects of doing so
anytime soon the council's own data on
actual construction of employment floor
space rather than just allocations and
planning permissions show a significant
and cronic shortfall amounting to
something like 70,000 meters squared
going back to at least 2010 if the
British ceramic tile sites redeveloped
that'll be great but it will only
scratch the surface and cancel out major
job losses that have already been
suffered its the chronic shortfall that
needs to be addressed and this outline
application is for market driven
Employment Development of 14,000 square
metres we already have businesses
interested in locating here we are
committed to delivery of the site at the
earliest opportunity starting within 12
months of planning permission enabling
works including the new access Junction
would be the first to be constructed and
then plots would be developed as
dictated by occupy demand
we calculate that the site could deliver
between approximately 200 to 400 jobs
which would be a huge boost the
council's economy manager has twice
expressed their written support for this
application for these reasons we're
committed to the principle of achieving
the policy s7 targets for reductions in
carbon emissions and carbon reduction
plans will be submitted with each
reserved matters application this
development can be at the zenith of the
green recovery that's been talked about
now
we genuinely understand people being
concerned about traffic and their
worries about road safety and pollution
however we did our calculations and
support submitted a transport assessment
and we are reassured that there are no
objections from Devon County Council
highways highways England all the
council's environmental health officers
in these regards we will be creating a
brand new highways access into the site
which will be located a quarter of a
mile from the school it will not be
going through the existing business park
which we hope corrects apparent
misunderstandings in some of the
consultation responses there are also no
objections from the council's
biodiversity landscape tree waste
management and spatial planning officers
nor are there objections from Natural
England the lead local flood authority
the Environment Agency the minerals
planning authority or Sibel Co it's a
clean bill of health from the council
tees and we will have a buffer zone
between the business park and the
libertines brook so there won't be an
impact on otters now my professional
opinion as a chartered town planner with
20 years experience this proposal
complies with development plan policy
the applicant and I very much welcome
your Planning Officers recommendation to
approve and we hope that you can endorse
this in your vote and as such give the
green light to creation of hundreds of
jobs thank you very much thank you
[Music]
so we now have the Waldman remember
counter patch hello okay yeah okay um -
counselor patch before I start my timed
speech and I just wanted to follow up
about the document I sent to committee
members yesterday which illustrated the
points aren't raised just to say that
while it might be handy if that document
is in front of you it's not at all
essential thank you I've got it in front
of me on my laptop okay thank you check
I'll begin them this is an application
to develop a greenfield site that is not
allocated for development in the local
plan I suggest that there is no case for
an exception cite the case for it relies
on data regarding the supplier and
demand for business and employment space
this evidence is demonstrably
out-of-date it was submitted in April
2019 on the supply side there's been
much progress in bringing forward
employment space including the granting
of planning permissions for some
significant sites and I referenced the
drawing which included in my
illustrations we have the former PCT
factory which is working progress land
at Garrett Kopp sprits plantation which
is an application for access road
progressing for mikela for Troy cycling
Spurs world permission granted
Alton Barton and a1 application
submitted rubra and a3 Commission
granted appeal together these bring in a
huge amount of employment space actually
with permission granted or in
development or going through the
planning process on the demand side
surveys of businesses seeking employment
space for expansion were audibly already
out to date prior to recent events the
national policy response to the Cobie 19
virus will lead to an unprecedented
drop-off in demand taking into account
both the supply demand side then I can
see no justifiable case to grant
permission on the greenfield site
there's not been allocated development
in the local clan you're likely to hear
the argument that the provision of
employment buildings creates new jobs
workers in those buildings of course it
does not vibrant economies create new
jobs and there is as has been pointed
out the likelihood of churn from the
Heathfield Industrial Estate in the
reports pack officers make the point
that the MPP F is clear that the
planning system needs to enable a rapid
response to changes in economic
circumstances all members of the council
will be aware it is not unreasonable to
expect a quarter of local businesses to
go a business in the future though
businesses mean empty employment space
in economic circles demand destruction
is usually discussed in terms of oil the
demand destruction for employment units
created by the cove in nineteen sports
is a material consideration of must be
considered there is no justification for
this is inception site trafficking road
safety concerns you've already heard a
lot on this particularly regarding the
crash the photo submitted by an objector
and shared to committee members
yesterday show the true picture of how
congested the road gets around a side
towards the primary school local people
will also be aware of the dangerous
junction at Binghamton the applicant
traffic assessment suggests that 96% of
traffic would arrive exit east of the
drum british direction conveniently I've
already both the school and the
dangerous Junction and Billington that
analysis is based on travel to work
analysis this concerns commuting term
from work of an employees and is nothing
at all to do with business trips heavy
vehicles would be likely to head in the
other direction past the school and out
through the dangerous junction at
Bennington this renders a traffic
sessemann void in my opinion and any
recommendations based upon it traffic in
air quality scientific understanding on
the health impacts of air pollution is
rapidly increasing headlines last 12
months include linking death rates to
Kovach 19 and with government's being
urged by probably health England I
believe to improve air quality around
schools I suggest this is also another
material consideration to reject
flooding is very important comments and
reports back by the Environment Agency
drew my attention to the sequential test
which group is and I'll just quote them
briefly
as you will be aware failure of the
sequential test
sufficient justification to refuse a
planning application a sequential test
and person site you are proposing to
develop with other available sites to
test sorry let's my buzzer going off
yeah sequence a sequential test and
present site Europe I'm frozen to
develop to see if others are available
that have less of a flood risk this has
been incorrectly reported in my view in
in the applicants flood risk assessment
they've chosen a point in flood zone 1
to form the basis of whether they need
to carry out sequential tests in fact
development is taking place in zone 2 or
3 2 & 3 also in the flood risk
assessment the proposed development
suggests big sorry the flood risk
assessment suggests that the proposed
development and all roads surrounding
the site or within flood zone 1 and
hence access and egress for motorized
and non-motorized vehicles not be
affected during third events actually
the map in their own flood risk
assessment shows that roads surrounding
the site are actually in flood zones 2 &
3 the proposed road crossing in their
plans is in flood zone 2 or 3 the
landscape strategy drawing in the flood
risk assessment labels the brook flood
area as a 1 in 25 years air event area
is this a mistake is clearly not
adequate
this year's floods already appear to
have gone beyond the hundred year plus
40 percent climate change allowance
boundary marked on the map that they
supplied the applicants flood risk
assessment does not appear to be a
reliable document there may be a chronic
facie grounds refusal planning
permission based on the issue of
sequential test alone and issue flag by
the environmental agency in the reports
pack in any case flooding of recent
months
challenges the assumption and
calculations regarding the protection of
the sites finally wildlife a risk of
extreme flood event this might lead to
runoff of polluted water into Lipton
brook
this would impact the sssi downstream
stove apart and the otters are protected
species that live in the brook
downstream based on the quality of the
other evidence submitted by the
applicant you'll forgive me if I do not
have the utmost confidence in that
submitted with respect to protection of
the bats I'm going 5 sound reasons
refusing this applique
I hope that committee members were also
bear in mind the design decline
emergency declaration this development
would remove a carbon sink area
furthermore I understand the executive
may be considering extending this
declaration to recognition of an
ecological emergency the risk to the SSI
and the protected species should be
viewed in light of the paucity of the
case of this as an exception site
sorry I've gone over a little bit there
okay thank you
right okay so I've got a couple of
people indicated to speak already so
Carol Jackie hook
thank you sure yeah I want to say
obviously very much support the creation
of job opportunities within teen bridge
and recognize the importance of creating
jobs near where residents live that are
easy to access by sustainable travel
loans as mentioned already animated from
our district to other areas in
particular
exter has grown during the time of our
local plan even though one of the main
tenets of that plan was to increase the
number of jobs per resident in our
district however that shouldn't in my
opinion mean we grab any opportunity
that comes our way and accept any offer
of employment lands each offer should be
weighed up against a range of policies
we have in our local plan and there will
be cases where that balance tips in
favor of accepting an offer of
employment land even though it's not an
allocated site in our local plan in my
view the recent approval at Kings Cosel
was one such paid it had dreamed
previously developed and was in a
location that was easily accessible by
foot
cycle and public transport on balance to
me it was reasonable to prioritize local
employment and the chance to provide
sustainably possible jobs however my
feeling is at the facts of policy
considerations at this site it's the
other way first and foremost the site is
not accessible by sustainable travel
means Devon County can't
correctly recall that although there are
buses serving the site they do not
coincide with a normal working day
indeed it's sad I feel that our economy
section comments refer to the site's
easy access to the main road network but
made only cursory mention of other means
of accessing the site with my climate
change hat on and in recognition that
transport is the biggest single
contributor to our district's carbon
emissions this is something that I can't
ignore we should not be encouraging
employment at sites where the prime
means of access is the private motor
vehicle adrian has correctly pointed out
a number of other employment sites that
have planning permission and could be
brought forward some of them recently
receiving plan of permission and all of
them in what sustainable locations than
this site just looking through our local
plan policies s22 our countryside
protection policy is quoted within the
report but there are some words missing
the policy also says particular account
should be taken of impact on overall
travel patterns the explanation that
accompanies the policy states that the
country site is suitable for limited
development this is not limited
development and I would suggest this
means this proposal does not satisfy
policy as 22 policy FEC 3 Rural
Employment policy is also quoted but
another bit of wording in that policy
requires the scale of employment to be
appropriate to the accessibility of the
site by public transport cycling and
walking the explanation of the policy
outlines that its purpose is to permit
small-scale economic expansion this is
not small-scale so I would suggest that
this proposal does not satisfy policy
ec3 and thanks to one of the objectors
who has worked out that this development
is a 450 percent increase on the smaller
libitum Business Park I haven't checked
those figures but I just think merely by
looking at the plan you can see that
it's about four times the size
if this was a housing site proposed on
the edge of a village and libertinism
and as a village in our local plan the
applicant would have to prove a housing
need in the local area and would only be
able to cater for that need so why is it
different for employment development in
a sense it isn't different because our
local plan policies as I just
interpreted them were designed to
achieve the same small-scale local needs
expansion and then there are policies
that are even referred to in the report
and conveniently forgotten so we've got
policy s9 sustainable travel requires
new development to be located and
designed to promote public transport
cycling and walking minimizing
dependence on the car policy s-21
villages development should be limited
to serve the villages need protect their
rural character and consistent with the
need to minimize travel again an
objector has usefully calculated that
this development will increase the
developed area of the village by 23%
that is not limited development again I
haven't checked those figures finally I
doubt that I'm disappointed that there's
no common reduction plan submitted with
this application and is a plan that's
required not a statement as referred to
in the report this I thought was going
to be part of the validation process for
applications that they wouldn't be
considered until a carbon reduction plan
was submitted it is not possible to
assess an application until we have this
information I'll carve a carbon neutral
target of 2025 is a serious commitment
we have made and it will be not be met
unless we have early sites of how each
development intends to satisfy our low
carbon policies for the reasons I have
given I recommend unless unless Adrian
did I missed it I recommend refusal also
can look at what he's already
recommended as this application is
contrary to our local plan policies as
22 ec 3s 9 and s 21 thank you chair
thank you well you'll be moving that as
a proposal because councillor patch had
to prayer
had had a predetermination so he was
only speaking as walked remember he
couldn't take part as a member of the
committee I'll say is it yeah who was
that please don't slip McGregor alright
thank you right I've got counselor
Wrigley next please yes thank you chair
councilman Gregor just jumped in there
and seconded it which is exactly what I
was going to do thank you to cancel a
jackie hook for summarizing all of the
absolutely good reasons why this should
be refused and thank you to councilor
patch for his detailed descriptions and
to our local residents for bringing
their points of view here as well this
is a development that is outside of the
local plan on green open space on that
basis alone we should not be allowing it
there's insufficient reason to make it
justifiable the applicant themselves
contradicted themselves in terms of the
available development land for work in
the in the district where they said in
the introduction first of all it's there
and it's being highly sought-after and
highly used and then saying it's not
being used enough we have existing
developed land in the local plan to work
we have existing spaces on many of our
more usable industrial states that
already exist they talked about in
heathfield site they talked about the
british ceramic tile site those are
places that should be developed along
these lines brownfield sites not a
greenfield site I urge the rest of the
committee please to support councillor
hooks proposal and reject this
application thank you
Thank You chair a little bit of
difficulty with the mute button now I
note in the in the application pack the
referrals to policy documents that were
considered during the consideration
process from the planning planning team
in terms of the presumption of in favor
of sustainable development what we have
noted quite often across not just the
district here but elsewhere is the
sustainable development is often viewed
as simply put it up and people will come
and that that is that is simply a
perspective to have on the on the idea
that any development is sustainable
simply because it's going to be a
business in terms of sustainable
development criteria it's very
interesting that we're talking about
employment and people travel thing to to
stay within the team breached history
bear in mind councilor hooks excellent
points about the fact it doesn't have
sustainable transport links to live it
in for a business type environment that
drug that immediately throws into the
question whether it could be a system
could be viewed as a sustainable
development in terms of carbon emissions
that having people travelling into liver
turn to work in an environment is going
to increase carbon emissions so the
presumption of in favor starts to look a
little bit shaky on on those grounds
alone I think in terms of you know
council a Wrigley's point it's a
greenfield site is there a need for it
it doesn't really look like it I mean
what we've tried to do as a council is
view both with the previous
administration with this one is to
improve the level of employment and the
level of pay that comes with that what
we're looking at here is a potentially
is a new location for people to relocate
from old locations and leave old
locations empty there's not really
adding to employment is
just shuffling the pack and on that
basis alone I think what we need to do
is that you take a karma look at the
employment development process more
widely but in this case actually is
reject this this application on the
basis of developing greenfield sites
there outside the local plan thank you
very much thank you
John Patrick Thank You Sherman
I agree councillor Hoboken councillor
patch that be very thorough with
expressing their concerns and I share
those concerns it's not embraced within
our plan there is land available for
employment use if he feel that is in our
plan also going off man its land
available at door which there are three
hectares of land available at dogfish I
also have concerns the fact that there's
a school nearby I pick up my grandson
from the school in Timnath I Drive
because at the distance and it's not
uncommon to see cars stretched 500
meters in all directions from the school
pick up time and that can be as early as
45 minutes before the school closes I
feel that slightly industrial units
nearby with all the additional traffic
accessing the site could increase the
likelihood of a child becoming harmed
and I certainly be voting against his
application thank you thank you
councillor not be quite brief as I think
everything's been said very impressed
with cancer patches statement and also
very interested to hear what so Simon KD
was saying I've used that road quite
often and obviously we've got blackboard
school there primary school and
obviously peak times in the mornings and
afternoons the amount of traffic with
parents making their children up to me
in any case the increase in the traffic
would be immense and I if I heard
rightly mentioned 420 workers did I get
that wrong not sure
I mean if that's correct time to make
the volume of traffic sure that's going
to put on if you had each worker I'll be
in the car
where are they were going to go that
particular area as well whether you've
seen photographs or not I don't know
become very flooded and where's where's
that water going to go and there's also
in a zone one flood risk area we've got
the option to consider as well which is
a site but I think everything else has
been been said that I would like to say
and I will be voting against this
application thank you thank you
councillor Bradford thank you very much
to everyone for all the information this
isn't in the local plan I don't believe
it's needed there's plenty of space that
he filled the air pollution threat to
the school it's very close to that I
believe it will destroy the rural
setting no benefit at all a heavy
industry is not conducive to a quiet
village I'll be voting against thank you
thank you council event
thank you I hear all the points that
people be making with interest firstly
this is a application for outline
permission so a lot of the issues have
been put on the table would come through
at a later stage but also point out that
Blackpool school has been to mention my
grandchildren actually go there the
school is separated from this proposed
site by the current Industrial Estate so
it's completely the other side and I
know as I get to pick my grandchildren
up the level of traffic and
what-have-you
it is going to be an issue but the
entrance being the position where it is
it's quite a way past where the cars
currently park to pick up their kids I
do agree there's a lot more work to be
done on this site and perhaps you should
come forward as part of the review for
sites but I just think we should focus
on the fact that we should be looking at
history was the development taking place
currently Heathfield
is an excellently of series of
developments it replaces the jobs that
were last lost their last year when the
tile company closed out we do need sites
we've faced a huge amount of criticism
over failure to deliver sites over the
last eight years we need to be very very
careful when we're looking at
prospective sites with good
communications good locations access to
the a 38 in just rejecting them without
due consideration yes there are
questions to be asked yes there are more
questions to be asked or I'm concerned
that we could potentially be throwing
away here at a reasonable site that
could be prepared delivered with the
appropriate conditions and that we're
listening issues which in reality on the
ground don't stand up thank you Thank
You councillor Hugh Cox
just briefly I think most things have
been said yet one thing that concerns me
is the increase in traffic through
picking tool in my ward and also the
where you join Ashburton road is a very
dangerous Junction which would be
increased traffic there which is a
concern to me okay thank you
I mean we have got seven counties where
they don't have any concerns on the
policy issue it's not in the local plan
I mean it's the same argument that was
rehearsed that cleans cars more although
it's not allocated in the local plan it
is still covered by the specific policy
related to such industrial developments
which are favored but I didn't have any
problems with the flooding because the
the site obviously excludes the area in
flood zone 3 I do find myself though
agreeing with some of what councillor
hook said right at the start in terms of
the sustainability of the site because
of the fact that so many people would
have to be travelling there so nobody
else having indicated to speak or
perhaps ask Anna Holloway or Rose if
they wish to come back now and talk
about those reasons that were given for
refusal which basically weren't any of
the ones in terms of policy local plan
well I mean no they were in they were
policies in the plan but it wasn't a
sort of the fact that's not allocated so
perhaps they can address the issues they
raised and the sustainability of the
site
Thank You chair firstly the relevant
policies are s22 not s21 cause it's not
in the village settlement so it is a
countryside location in terms of
policies s22 and ec3 these are permitted
in principle of this kind of development
within the open countryside so the
proposal given the persistence under
delivery of employment against the local
plan is supported from a local and
policy viewpoint and that's what came
through from the comments from my
spatial planning colleagues in terms of
the flood risk issues it is in the
development area is within flood zone
one with the parts within flood those
two and three set aside for a wetland
area and there's been no objection
subject to the conditions from the lead
local flood authority or Environment
Agency so it does meet that sequential
test in terms of the biodiversity
matters there's a full approach has been
carried out in consultation natural
England and so those details have been
resolved and the conditions proposed
would protect the adult corridor along
Levitan Brook and that would also
protect the otters in terms of the
location and the Highways Network there
is no objection from the highways
England or from the local Highways
Authority the crossing is proposed
across the road which something that
County had asked for and a condition for
a travel plan would be imposed this is a
site which does have good connectivity
auto transport network and therefore
Guilford and the fact that we do have
persistent under delivery on the local
plan requirements for employment space
this proposal is considered by officers
to be acceptable
I covered all the points for something
else well it was just a sustainability
that policies for the the points perhaps
I'll bring in counselor who try to say
at this point that members of the public
who are speaking shouldn't be using the
messaging system to add further common
so members can please ignore any
comments sent from members of the public
who are currently in the meeting
councillor hook did you want to we need
to have reasons that you put forward as
to why this would be against the officer
recommendation and if you rely to what
was just being said you could clarify
the reasons for refusal you're putting
forward please think again and just to
reiterate a couple points and this might
only have good accessibility by private
motor vehicle it doesn't have good
public transport access which is the
only realistic mode of access really
looks like a exactly this is not a
realistic cycling distance of large
centers of population yeah by safety
safe means so we're talking about what
is there there are three bus routes
there's the extra Plymouth one there's a
loss on Wednesday and Friday and there's
one of the beam which leaves this area
at something like between 2:00 and 3:00
p.m. so you know it is not so
realistically my losses so it is not
excessive sustainably accessible the
real quick thing the reasons why I only
have been personally referred in my
speech and refer to them in reasons for
refusal of matters related to fire
diversity ecology I personally wouldn't
include them in reasons for refusal if
because we don't have the backend of the
various offices and to those matters and
that's why previously received
interesting two reasons
that can be defended the reasons I think
can be defended in relation to our local
policies s22 countryside protection ec
through Rural Employment s nying
sustainable travel and I've heard and I
just said on s21 villages maybe I
misinterpreted it village policy
obviously is outside the village
envelope this proposal I took that to be
covered by policy s21 but if it isn't
well then happy for that to be taken out
and just leave the other two three
policies as reasons for refusals
basically for the reasons of
sustainability but in particular regard
to travel and the scale of development
proposed in the countryside so that
those would be my reasons okay and and
the reasons why are we going against
officer recommendations because you
consider that those particular reasons
are ones that stand up as as a reason
for refusal which hadn't been you know
sort of otherwise given given support
outside of the Council of otherwise
there aren't reasons put forward against
what you've just sent I think Colin
trying to get my head round that one
councillor hook basically he said really
exactly she said and I read out I mean
I'm happy to read it again but s22 there
was a policy that went read out about
impact on travel patterns enjoyment
again it was talking about small-scale
economic expansion for local needs which
this isn't and sustainable travel s9
requires us to promote public transport
cycling and walking and minimize
dependence on the car so on that basis I
don't believe this proposal satisfies
those three policies okay thank you
that's that will be the the reasons it
Rose is there anything you wish to
question or
at this point
you
Thank You chair I just wanted to
highlight that
there is no support from the our spatial
planning colleagues for a policy refusal
of this nature and as Anna has
highlighted there are a series of
conditions attached to this mission that
would look to provide additional
transport benefit we're also as a
council investing in and supportive of
the proposals to improve and upgrade the
88 - link between news nabbit and run
bridges which was significantly improved
the cycle connectivity so you have
bringing much better cycle connectivity
to this part of the world as a
consequence of those significant works
there and I do understand have sympathy
with the fact that this perhaps in an
ideal location in terms of public
transport access but it is incredibly
well located for the highway network and
the range and choice of sites that we
need to have available to make sure that
we're providing choice within our local
market there is very limited floor space
available that he's filled at the moment
we don't need to demonstrate need as
part of the justification for the
delivery of employment land it's not
like a retail proposal and if there is
no need and if there is no market demand
for this it simply won't come forward
but my understanding is that there's an
significant latent demand for a site of
this nature and it's very difficult with
employment floor space and that will be
occupied by individual organizations to
get the carbon reduction statements
upfront it's much very easier and better
to get a comprehensive and significantly
enhanced carbon reduction plan asses
individual occupiers once we know who
they are what the nature of their
businesses and what they will be doing
how big their building will be and what
their individual requirements are which
is why in this instance we considered it
was better left to reserve massive stage
but fundamentally and I would just urge
caution in refusing plan information for
this route it's like where as councillor
has noted there are no tech
for objections to the development okay
I've got few other speakers counselor
Carl Clough yes Thank You chairman it
was a bit late now I was just going to
support refusal of this application I
think we should listen to the people who
live around there a hundred and ten
people have taken the trouble to object
to this the world members are not happy
with it with with it and even the MP is
against it so I really think we should
listen to the people who live there and
who would have to live with this
development and then I don't think
there's a need for it it's outside the
local plan and I think it should be
refused this as their proposed thank you
and councillor Kurzweil you've not
spoken before so I'll bring you in next
Thank You chairman I've listened to this
debate very carefully and apart from all
the planning issues that councillor Hook
has brought up and the policy issues I
do I am very concerned that when we
bring forward employment land even on
residential sites we now have to bring
forward employment land which never
seems to get built and it reverts back
to residential I do wonder whether the
need is actually there and also I'm
thinking on the situation that we've
been through at the moment where many
many people have been working from home
and it's widely known now that big
business is have realized that their
workers working from home works just as
well then having big office blocks etc
and people going into work every day so
the carbon footprint has decreased
massively over the last few months and I
am seriously worried about how we're
going forward
in this day and age trying to bring
forward more employment land when we
know that in our area we have more than
enough Thank You Janice
thank you I've got people who've spoken
before us know if it's the hands are
still up or if they wish to come back
but it will have to be brief please
cancel a hook
I didn't want right Thank You councillor
McGregor Thank You chair it was just
just to come back on an additional
reason for refusal when one of the
policy elements that was considered was
landscape Protection Enhancement now
when you look at the photographs that
were provided by the planning team in
the presentation
that's quite a beautiful open piece of
land with great vistas to be fair and
sticking a fourteen thousand square foot
in there and if it is for distribution
it's likely to be significant height as
well so in in real terms that you know
that I think you know there's no there's
no way that that could be considered
landscape protection and enhancement so
that was one element in in terms of the
employment use demand I think it's fair
to point out and I think a few other
councillors have mentioned this already
a few other members of the committee
have mentioned we have a significant
number of already approved plans for
employment land and employment areas to
be delivered and the question I have to
ask is why aren't those being delivered
if there is a demand for employment land
so that's that's the first question we
have one there Newton Abbot between you
and let's go as well we've got another
one at Baker's yard which is employment
and residential that this land is not
being delivered and it seems that what
we're doing is just stacking up outline
planning applications or planning
approvals on the basis that we have
wanted one of these will kind of wider
basis is what are we actually doing to
pursue existing planning applications
that have been approved for employment
land thank you all right
okay well the officer said there's no
need for them to demonstrate me so that
is the reason why as far as landscape
concern this is only outlined you've got
the term expressway beyond
Praeger meals beyond that so I don't
think we need to bring in that at this
late stage because counselor hook didn't
include it in her up in her actual
reasons counselor moment
thank you just very very quickly can I
just confirm we have consulted with all
of the appropriate approved bodies and
it listed it from them their opinions
that they basically have no objection to
this development that should this
permission be refused it goes to appeal
the independent inspector would go to
those same bodies to seek their opinions
and their experience over recent years
the feedback from that is if the
approved consul T bodies have said it's
acceptable the inspector has accepted
those words and if we go down that route
the amount of firm cost the team bridge
will be significant if this application
was rejected against the officers
approval I think the reason for refusal
that councilor hooks putting forward
doesn't include any of those wide range
of issues including flooding highways
and so on it's on the sustainability
issues in which case it would just be
that it would be considered that an
appeal is my understanding
I appreciate that clarity thank you
Thank You counsel Bradford Thank You
chair I just wanted to say that Rose
recommended we passed this with
conditions and I wanted to reiterate
that conditions are discharged without
public consultation which was set before
by a public speaker I just wanted to
reiterate that thank you thank you right
so we're coming back to the motion that
councillor hook has proposed that it be
refused for the reasons outlined
okay so shall we now go on that was
quite clear can we can make it have it
reiterated I haven't I haven't had a
chance to write down what the reason for
refusal would be make sure that we're
absolutely clear about they're not the
generality of the reasons but the
specificity of the reason for refusal in
relation to the policies that counselor
has mentioned that's been proposed thank
you yep so the reasons for the refusal
that I'm suggesting are contrary to
policy s22 the countryside policy
specifically with regard to the aspect
of not taken into account the impact of
overall travel patterns in that it's not
accessible in a sustainable manner for
the CEC three rural employment the
intent of that policy is to announce
small-scale employment development and
this is not small scale and also with
regard to policy yes knowing sustainable
travel in particular in relation to the
fact that development should promote
public transport cycling and walking
minimizing dependence on the car which I
don't believe this does and with regard
to those three three policies which of
course are all subjective policies and
all can be argued out I mean you know we
hear it argue one way sometimes in
reports and another way another time
they are entirely subjective and can be
argued either way with with a bus
service that doesn't work in normal
working hours and provide that service
this is not the sustainable height and
you know I feel very strongly you know
with my climate change how long that
this really should be refused it's not
the way we should be going in in we
haven't sustainable sites for employment
already with Commission and we must
bring those forward thank you okay then
rosettes well - it's clear to me I think
so we've got the reasons for refusal
right if we go through the vote now
please I'll ask Chris in a moment to go
through the the name
so the the motion is called refusal so
if you want it to be refused you vote
for if you don't want it to be refused
to vote against so that's clear because
it's okay Chris yeah so it comes the
Bradford Paul counselor Upstate
counselor Clarence for refusal Paul
counselor Cox for counselor Hayes counts
Jeffrey counselor counselor Jenks
[Music]
counselor Caswell also Caswell beg your
pardon for Chancellor McGregor all our
counselor Nuttall counselor Parker mink
sorry counselor not leave sir or
counselor Parker or counselor Patrick or
counselor wrigley for counselor Haines
for and counselor Goodman for okay I'll
just
I think that's 1941 one abstention
I'll make it 18 four on one abstention
okay yes chair
in form one abstention okay thank you so
that's carried
so that means permission has been
refused for the reasons given by counsel
hook thank you so we could move on from
that that was item six that was the last
one under item six item seven is the
peel decisions to note the appeal
decisions made okay they weren't happy
just to to note those over is indicated
right in which case then that is the
last item on the agenda item seven so
the agenda is now finished and thank you
all very much for your forbearance today
and I'll just hang on for a quick word
with perhaps the offices afterwards on a
couple of things and see you all soon -
bye for now
Tony YouTube off yeah I like to wait
till it's finished okay thank you
hi Mike can I hang on the second video I
just want to quick yep chisel